其他人:师傅你怎么了
Others: Master, what's wrong?
Shure: 说我什么坏话了
Shure: Are you talking bad about me?
Shure: 又啊
Shure: Again?
Shure: （歌词）他要到西天拜佛取真经
Shure: (Lyrics) He is going to the West to worship Buddha and get the scriptures.
其他人:其实底料都是一样的
Others: Actually, the base ingredients are the same.
Shure: 咱们晚饭吃什么呀老板
Shure: What are we having for dinner, boss?
其他人:你调的那个面包坯子都是一样
Others: The dough you made is the same.
Shure: 咱们晚饭吃什么呀
Shure: What are we having for dinner?
Shure: 老板
Shure: Boss?
Jake:麦当劳麦当劳汉堡
Jake: McDonald's, McDonald's burgers.
Tasha: 麦当劳汉堡
Tasha: McDonald's burgers.
Shure: 那什什么时候点一下呀
Shure: So, when are we ordering?
Jake:啊现在是啊
Jake: Uh, now.
Lucia:啊现在拿下来是吧
Lucia: Uh, now we take it down, right?
Tasha: 对
Tasha: Yeah.
Lucia:对嗯我看我看
Lucia: Yeah, let me check.
其他人:哪有你这样打的
Others: Who hits like that?
Jake:哈哈哈
Jake: Hahaha.
Lucia:我觉得他这
Lucia: I think he...
Lucia:他这个已经达到那个打蛋器的五档了
Lucia: He's already at the fifth speed of the mixer.
Jake:啊哈哈哈
Jake: Ah, hahaha.
Shure: 给你
Shure: Here you go.
Shure: （歌词）他要到西天拜佛去取经
Shure: (Lyrics) He is going to the West to worship Buddha and get the scriptures.
Shure: 所以到底说我什么坏话了
Shure: So, what bad things did you say about me?
Tasha: 不不不
Tasha: No, no, no.
Jake:麦当劳汉堡
Jake: McDonald's burgers.
Tasha: 我还以为你真会
Tasha: I thought you really would.
Shure: 们可以
Shure: We can.
Jake:哎搜不到麦当劳
Jake: Hey, can't find McDonald's.
Shure: 卧槽
Shure: Damn.
Jake:为啥
Jake: Why?
Shure: 这没有麦当劳
Shure: There's no McDonald's.
Tasha: 停停
Tasha: Stop, stop.
Shure: 不会吧
Shure: No way.
Shure: 你去那个麦当劳小程序里看一看
Shure: Check the McDonald's mini program.
其他人:美团呢
Others: What about Meituan?
Tasha: 第一次要打到他有
Tasha: The first time it has to be...
Shure: 卧槽真没有麦当劳
Shure: Damn, no McDonald's.
Jake:谁有麦当劳小程序
Jake: Who has the McDonald's mini program?
Jake:你有吗我有我有
Jake: Do you have it? I have it.
Shure: 我有
Shure: I have it.
Tasha: 我有
Tasha: I have it.
Jake:来来来试试
Jake: Come on, try it.
Jake:试试
Jake: Try it.
Tasha: 麦当劳汉堡
Tasha: McDonald's burger.
Tasha: 麦麦麦当劳汉堡
Tasha: Mc-Mc-McDonald's burger.
Jake:因为没有
Jake: Because they don't have it.
Jake:美团上没有
Jake: It's not on Meituan.
Lucia:你
Lucia: You...
Tasha: 嗯这样子
Tasha: Hmm, like this.
Tasha: 有这种细密的小气泡
Tasha: It has these tiny bubbles.
Shure: 啥没说啥你哎呀
Shure: What? I didn't say anything, oh come on.
Shure: 好烦啊你
Shure: You're so annoying.
Shure: 我说那个明天有一个
Shure: I said there's an event tomorrow.
Shure: 就是明天我们那个有一个活动的环节
Shure: We have an activity segment tomorrow.
Shure: 就是类似于
Shure: It's like...
Shure: 咱俩那天去那个大榕寺跳海
Shure: Like when we went to the Banyan Temple that day to dive.
Shure: 那个活动
Shure: That event.
Shure: 就是一个二手拍卖
Shure: It's like a second-hand auction.
Shure: 然后
Shure: And then...
Shure: 好的好的我摘了
Shure: Okay, okay, I got it.
Shure: 什么东西啊我靠
Shure: What the heck is this?
Shure: 好好好你是神医师
Shure: Alright, alright, you're a miracle worker.
Shure: 所以API到底是什么呀
Shure: So what exactly is an API?
Shure: 嗨这个呀
Shure: Oh, this thing.
Shure: 点不了吧
Shure: Can't order it, right?
Shure: 这是到店取餐
Shure: This is for in-store pickup.
Alice:这两个加起来
Alice: Add these two together.
Jake:那他他准备
Jake: Then he... he's preparing.
Alice:打开了
Alice: It's open.
Jake:师傅准备找个跑腿
Jake: The master is preparing to find a courier.
Shure: 啊也行
Shure: Ah, that works too.
其他人:离多远我们过去
Others: How far is it, we'll go there.
Jake:2.4公里
Jake: 2.4 kilometers.
Shure: 啊没有
Shure: Ah, no.
Shure: 目前没有
Shure: Not right now.
Shure: 你给我卖了干嘛
Shure: Why did you sell it to me?
Shure: 我能干嘛
Shure: What can I do with it?
Shure: 怎么男老师
Shure: Why male teacher?
Shure: 想想想玩一玩
Shure: Think, think, think, play around.
Shure: 可以的没没问题
Shure: Sure, no problem.
Shure: （歌词）有一副扇面
Shure: (lyrics) There is a fan surface
Shure: （歌词）子孝孙贤
Shure: (lyrics) Filial children and virtuous grandchildren
Shure: （歌词）哒哒哒
Shure: (lyrics) Da da da
Jake:勾人呢啊勾了
Jake: Hooked someone, huh, hooked.
Shure: 啊勾了勾
Shure: Ah, hooked, hooked.
Shure: 是不是睡着了勾
Shure: Did you fall asleep?
Shure: 勾
Shure: Hooked.
Shure: 你在睡觉吗
Shure: Are you sleeping?
Shure: 是的
Shure: Yes.
Shure: 你在干嘛
Shure: What are you doing?
Katrina: 我在工作呀
Katrina: I'm working.
Shure: 啊点个餐
Shure: Ah, order some food.
Shure: 然后戴个眼镜
Shure: And then wear some glasses.
Shure: 我能我能当
Shure: I can, I can be...
Shure: 不是我才反应过来我能给你
Shure: No, I just realized I can give you...
Shure: 我才反应过来这句话怎么
Shure: I just realized, how is this sentence...
Shure: 我我卖的
Shure: I, I sell...
Shure: 我是我是什么
Shure: What am I?
Shure: idol toy吗啊
Shure: Idol toy, huh?
其他人：喊他过来
Others: Call him over.
Shure: 好了好了好了
Shure: Alright, alright, alright.
Jake:他干嘛呢
Jake: What's he doing?
Jake:他干活呢
Jake: He's working.
Shure: 他对在干活
Shure: Yeah, he's working.
Jake:好嘞
Jake: Got it.
其他人:我操逆天了
Others: Damn, that's amazing.
Jake:QBZ
Jake: QBZ
其他人:我真扯到波塔了
Others: I really pulled off a miracle.
其他人：吓了半天
Others: Scared me for a while.
其他人：没收到草
Others: Didn't receive the grass.
其他人：开机吗
Others: Is it on?
Jake:你们公共区域在哪啊
Jake: Where is your common area?
其他人:公共区域应该在台湾区那个什么Patro
Others: The common area should be in the Taiwan area, something like Patro.
Jake:那你
Jake: Then you...
Jake:那你弄过来呗
Jake: Then bring it over.
其他人:我已经忘了康大该怎么软硬我怎么来
Others: I already forgot how to deal with Kangda, how should I do it?
Lucia:为什么会好像没什么
Lucia: Why does it seem like nothing...
Lucia:变化呀他应该会怎么样
Lucia: Changed? What should it be like?
Jake:就直接copy过去
Jake: Just copy it over directly.
Jake:直接copy一个软件啊remove
Jake: Just copy a software and remove it.
Jake:你点了吗
Jake: Did you click it?
Shure: 我没点呢
Shure: I haven't clicked it yet.
Jake:没点好嘞
Jake: Haven't clicked? Okay.
Tasha: 没关系我看他们用厨师机要打5分钟
Tasha: It's fine, I saw them use a stand mixer for 5 minutes.
Tasha: 这种手抽机的话可能要打个10分钟吧
Tasha: If it's a hand mixer, it might take about 10 minutes.
Jake:你坐着打吧
Jake: You can sit and mix it.
Jake:要不抱着打吧
Jake: Or hold it and mix.
Lucia:请
Lucia: Please.
Jake:好 10分钟之后见
Jake: Alright, see you in 10 minutes.
Jake:哈哈哈哈哈
Jake: Hahahahaha.
Lucia:休息一下马上回来
Lucia: Take a break, we'll be right back.
Lucia:好我们可以咔了哈哈
Lucia: Alright, we can cut now, haha.
Tasha: 这个状态是很不对的
Tasha: This doesn't seem right.
Jake:哈
Jake: Huh?
Alice:妈的香薰
Alice: Damn, the aroma.
Tasha: 如果实在不行
Tasha: If it really doesn't work,
Tasha: 那就加面粉吧
Tasha: Then just add some flour.
其他人:你可以再加点啊
Others: You can add some more.
其他人:再稍微加一点
Others: Just add a bit more.
Tasha: 再看一看吧
Tasha: Let's check again.
其他人:水或者什么加太多
Others: Did we add too much water or something?
其他人:什么都没加多呀
Others: Nothing was added too much.
Alice:你也要来吗
Alice: Are you joining too?
其他人:不是每个都各各多了一克
Others: It's just that each one is a gram more.
Lucia:可以看一眼吗
Lucia: Can I take a look?
Alice:可以
Alice: Sure.
Tasha: 你再说每个多一克就会影响这么大
Tasha: Are you saying each gram more makes such a big difference?
其他人:你看现在是不是稍微熟
Others: Does it look a bit cooked now?
Tasha: 啊再继续抽吧
Tasha: Ah, just keep mixing.
其他人：可能因为咱们那个料是不是好了
Others: Maybe our ingredients are good now.
Tasha: 好了不要指责配方
Tasha: Alright, let's not blame the recipe.
Tasha: 要要好好打他
Tasha: We need to mix it well.
Shure:  传给谁
Shure: Who should I send it to?
Tasha: 把那个他把那个空气抽干应该就
Tasha: If we get the air out of it, it should be fine.
Shure: 这是谁的手机
Shure: Whose phone is this?
Jake:买几个弹弓过来玩
Jake: Let's buy some slingshots to play with.
Lucia:弹弓过来
Lucia: Slingshots?
Jake:因为很多是石子哦
Jake: Because there are a lot of pebbles, you know.
Lucia:哦
Lucia: Oh.
Jake:砸玻璃哈哈哈哈
Jake: Breaking the glass, hahaha.
Shure: 哈哈哈录着呢录着呢
Shure: Haha, it's recording, it's recording.
Shure: 都都给你录下来了
Shure: It's all recorded for you.
Jake:看看看哪位邻居的玻璃比较脆
Jake: Let's see whose neighbor's glass is the most fragile.
Lucia:他们不会没取我的吧
Lucia: They didn't take mine, did they?
Jake:啊那你你的号再给他们说一下吧
Jake: Ah, then tell them your number again.
Lucia:我没有看到有我的呀
Lucia: I didn't see mine there.
Shure: 他有一些好像
Shure: There are some, I think.
Shure: 他说是虚拟号然后没有
Shure: He said it's a virtual number and then nothing.
Jake:写的名字
Jake: The name written.
Jake:是你的名字吗
Jake: Is it your name?
Lucia:嗯我写的名字是猪先生
Lucia: Yeah, the name I wrote is Mr. Pig.
Jake:哈哈你的皮肤
Jake: Haha, your skin.
Lucia:对我觉得他好像
Lucia: Yeah, I think he...
Lucia:我觉得他没有
Lucia: I think he didn't.
Lucia:不会忘了吧
Lucia: He wouldn't forget, right?
Lucia:靠让我再进去看一眼
Lucia: Oh, let me go in and check again.
Lucia:不会吧不会吧不会吧
Lucia: No way, no way, no way.
Jake:不会吧不会吧
Jake: No way, no way.
Jake:飞机
Jake: A plane.
Shure: 哪呢
Shure: Where?
Jake:这个角度
Jake: This angle.
Shure: 不能瞎看
Shure: Don't look randomly.
Shure: 这边
Shure: Over here.
Jake:看我
Jake: Look at me.
Shure: 哇你要
Shure: Wow, you're going to...
Shure: 哈哈哈徒手搓核弹了是吧
Shure: Haha, you're going to rub a nuke by hand, right?
Lucia:真的我觉得他
Lucia: Really, I think he...
Katrina: 点餐吗要不
Katrina: Should we order food?
Katrina: 点屋里
Katrina: Order from inside.
Katrina: 我靠我隐形眼镜掉了
Katrina: Oh no, I dropped my contact lens.
Shure: 没了找不见了
Shure: It's gone, can't find it.
Katrina: 我以为放那个我那隐形眼镜盒里摸
Katrina: I thought I put it in my contact lens case, but...
Katrina: 只摸到一格
Katrina: There's only one.
Katrina: 我要点一个外卖
Katrina: I need to order delivery.
Katrina: 我现在就是一直能看得见一直看不见
Katrina: Now I can see and then I can't see.
Shure: 你多少度的
Shure: What's your prescription?
Shure: 600度
Katrina: 600
Katrina: 600.
Katrina: 哈哈哈哈哈太抽象
Katrina: Hahahaha, so abstract!
Katrina: 找谁啊点
Katrina: Who should I ask?
Shure: 要不
Shure: How about...
Shure: 我那有450
Shure: I have 450.
Shure: 你先对付用着
Shure: You can use it for now.
Katrina: 没事我现在点一个找
Katrina: It's okay, I'll find someone now.
Katrina: 找谁点他
Katrina: Who should I ask?
Shure: 找他点对
Shure: Ask him, yeah.
Katrina: 吃什么
Katrina: What to eat?
其他人:你会做吗
Others: Can you cook?
Shure: 不是点点点点点外卖啊
Shure: No, I mean order takeout.
其他人:那个在在啊
Others: That one, over there.
Shure: 那呢那呢那呢那呢
Shure: There, there, there, there.
其他人:那那那是在薛明主那还是在孟威尔那
Others: Is it at Xue Mingzhu's or Meng Weier's?
Jake:对他也在点了
Jake: Yeah, he's ordering too.
Shure: 他说有一些是虚拟号
Shure: He said some are virtual numbers.
Shure: 就是他根据尾号找不到
Shure: He can't find them based on the last digits.
Lucia:啊这样的吗
Lucia: Really?
Lucia:但是我给他发了截图
Lucia: But I sent him a screenshot.
Lucia:就是那个取件码
Lucia: It's the pickup code.
Katrina: 又想吃冰淇淋
Katrina: I want ice cream again.
Shure: 不知道啊
Shure: I don't know.
Shure: （歌词）这一幅扇面画的水晶宫啊
Shure: (singing) This fan painting of the Crystal Palace...
其他人:这晚上在这debug岂不是非常的舒适
Others: Debugging here at night would be so comfortable.
其他人：有没有可能不debug 更舒适呢
Others: Is it possible to be more comfortable without debugging?
Shure: 就我们在这吃吃喝喝不更舒适吗
Shure: Wouldn't it be more comfortable just eating and drinking here?
Shure: 怎么能把自己PUA成这个样子了
Shure: How did we PUA ourselves like this?
Shure: 哈哈哈哈
Shure: Hahahaha
Shure: 哎呦我的妈呀
Shure: Oh my gosh.
Jake:啊哈哈哈
Jake: Hahaha
Shure: 他他说晚上在这提bug
Shure: He said debugging here at night...
Shure: 岂不是非常的舒适
Shure: Wouldn't that be so comfortable?
Shure: 我说有没有可能你在这坐着更舒适呢
Shure: I said, is it possible you'd be more comfortable just sitting here?
Jake:哈哈哈反思
Jake: Hahaha, reflect on it.
Shure: 哈哈哈反思
Shure: Hahaha, reflect on it.
其他人:我要反思
Others: I need to reflect.
其他人:我是爱反思的中国人
Others: I am a reflective Chinese person.
Jake:挺好
Jake: Pretty good.
Shure: 喂你好
Shure: Hello?
Jake:群里问问吧
Jake: Ask in the group.
Shure: 哎好
Shure: Oh, okay.
Shure: 我马上来取一下
Shure: I'll go get it right now.
Jake:发了哈
Jake: Sent it, huh?
其他人:好嘞安慕希菠萝酸奶麦旋风
Others: Alright, an Ambrosial pineapple yogurt McFlurry.
其他人:我靠这个看着就想吃
Others: Wow, just looking at it makes me want to eat it.
Jake:买一赠一了
Jake: Buy one, get one free.
Jake:甜点不能太多
Jake: Don't have too many desserts.
Shure: 你好
Shure: Hello.
Shure: 谢谢你
Shure: Thank you.
Shure: （歌词）这一副善良
Shure: (Lyrics) This kindness
Shure: （歌词）子孝孙贤嗯嗯
Shure: (Lyrics) Filial children and virtuous grandchildren, mm-mm
Tasha: 麦当劳汉堡
Tasha: McDonald's burger.
Tasha: 麦麦麦当劳汉堡
Tasha: Mc, Mc, McDonald's burger.
Shure: Sakira
Shure: Tequila.
Shure: 慢点慢点慢点慢点
Shure: Slow down, slow down, slow down, slow down.
Jake:哎是是不快他很难变快
Jake: Yeah, it's hard for it to get fast.
Jake:Sakira是一首歌是吧
Jake: Tequila is a song, right?
Shure: 啊不是就是龙舌兰
Shure: Ah, no, it's just tequila.
Jake:就是有一首歌
Jake: There's a song too.
Shure: 抹黑错那是不是
Shure: "La Bamba," right?
Jake:不是不是也是一首歌
Jake: No, no, there's also a song.
Tasha: 这个托呢
Tasha: What about this tray?
其他人:应该还有谁
Others: Who else should have it?
其他人:没点吗
Others: Didn't you order?
其他人：你们都点过
Others: You all ordered.
Shure: 都点过了吧谁没点
Shure: Everyone's ordered, right? Who hasn't?
Tasha: 这个的托呢
Tasha: What about this tray?
Jake:托
Jake: Tray.
Shure: 所以你为什么骂我是纯爱比
Shure: So why are you calling me a pure love idiot?
Shure: 纯爱怎么了怎么了怎么了怎么了
Shure: What's wrong with pure love? What's wrong? What's wrong? What's wrong?
Shure: 就喜欢抱着睡
Shure: Just like to hug while sleeping.
Shure: 素怎么了
Shure: What's wrong with it?
其他人：双休吗对
Others: Double weekends, right?
其他人：双休通常双休
Others: Usually double weekends.
其他人：但周末都工作
Others: But work on weekends.
其他人：哈哈哈这这也可以不工作
Others: Haha, yeah, but you can also not work.
其他人：反正都是自己的活呗
Others: It's all your own work anyway.
其他人：对就把自己活干完
Others: Yeah, just finish your own work.
其他人：你也可以不工
Others: You can also not work.
其他人：就是周中也可以不工
Others: Even during the week, you can not work.
其他人：他那个签到是你
Others: His check-in is for you
其他人：只要在北京市内都挺好
Others: As long as it's within Beijing, it's fine
其他人：对然后一签也可以签一天啊
Others: Yeah, and you can check in for a day too
其他人：你不去实习生吗
Others: Aren't you going to the internship?
其他人：你不去也没人管你
Others: No one will care if you don't go
其他人：但是你只要把活干了
Others: Just get the work done
其他人：但你要活干不要加班
Others: But you have to get the work done without overtime
其他人：他不是打卡导向
Others: It's not about clocking in
其他人：是任务导向
Others: It's task-oriented
Shure: 真的 吗
Shure: Really?
Shure: 哦原来是这样
Shure: Oh, I see
Shure: 你看我多好多好哄着
Shure: See how good I am at making you happy
其他人：debug了啊
Others: Debug done?
Shure: Sakira这一幅山面子孝孙贤
Shure: Sakira is this mountain, a filial grandson
Katrina: 6.6公里我操
Katrina: 6.6 kilometers, damn
Katrina: 附近都没有卖眼镜的
Katrina: There's no place nearby that sells glasses
Shure: 啊好香啊
Shure: Ah, it smells so good
Shure: 我们是不是应该一会排练一下
Shure: Should we rehearse a bit later
Shure: 明天的歌曲来着
Shure: For tomorrow's song?
Katrina: 哦忘了哈哈哈
Katrina: Oh, I forgot, haha
Shure: 工人怎么变批人了
Shure: How did the workers become a batch of people
Shure: 这两天
Shure: These past two days
Katrina: 再待两天
Katrina: Stay two more days
Katrina: 我完蛋了
Katrina: I'm doomed
Jake:哈哈一个批房啊
Jake: Haha, it's a batch room
Katrina: 哈哈哈
Katrina: Hahaha
Katrina: 嗯我要完蛋了
Katrina: Hmm, I'm doomed
Jake:点完了都点完了
Jake: All ordered, all ordered
Jake:都点了
Jake: All ordered
Lucia:我还没点
Lucia: I haven't ordered yet
Jake:哦好
Jake: Oh, okay
Jake:你选哪一個
Jake: Which one do you want?
Jake:加一看你选哪一个加1
Jake: Add one, let's see which one you choose, add one
Jake:哼这包还在这
Jake: Hmph, this bag is still here
Jake:包还没变过呢
Jake: The bag hasn't changed
Jake:开始魔法
Jake: Start the magic
Tasha: 知道那里出了问题
Tasha: Know where the problem is
Jake:你猜是谁
Jake: Guess who it is
Tasha: 好了洗洗我们下一个吧
Tasha: Okay, let's move on to the next one
Jake:不是
Jake: No
Shure: 什么好
Shure: What's good?
其他人:咱们往里面加点那个
Others: Let's add a bit of that inside.
Tasha: 那也得出来再加了
Tasha: But we have to add it after we take it out.
Shure: 这是你说的那个赵老师是吧
Shure: Is this the Teacher Zhao you were talking about?
Shure: 那这是哪个
Shure: So which one is this?
Shure: 这个是哎呀
Shure: This one is... oh man.
Shure: 太难认了
Shure: It's too hard to recognize.
Shure: 那你不是说26号找哪个哪个哪个
Shure: Didn't you say we should meet on the 26th?
Shure: 就是那是早上跟我说的吧
Shure: Wasn't that what you told me in the morning?
Shure: 还是哪个来着
Shure: Or was it something else?
Shure: 哦好的好的
Shure: Oh, okay, okay.
Shure: 哎
Shure: Hey.
Shure: 慢慢认慢慢人
Shure: Slowly recognizing, slowly.
Shure: 整的我跟在这在这认亲戚似的
Shure: It's like I'm here recognizing relatives.
Shure: 一个个
Shure: One by one.
Shure: Sakira 该怎么去形容你最
Shure: Sakira, how should I describe you the best?
Shure: 我我我记我也记得
Shure: I, I, I remember, I also remember.
Shure: 我记脸也特别特别慢
Shure: I remember faces very slowly.
Shure: 也不能说记脸吧
Shure: Well, not really faces.
Shure: 记人名会慢一些
Shure: I remember names slowly.
Shure: 记脸还好其实
Shure: Faces are actually okay.
Shure: 就到现在
Shure: Until now.
Shure: 这些室友的全名我可能还没记全
Shure: I probably still haven't remembered all my roommates' full names.
其他人：他这个还对塞纳的吐司的版本有要求
Others: He even has requirements for the version of Sena's toast.
其他人：我第一次听
Others: This is the first time I'm hearing this.
Shure: 哎
Shure: Hey.
其他人：你在干嘛呢
Others: What are you doing?
Shure: 那桌子上还有一沓这啊啊
Shure: There's still a stack on the table there, right?
Lucia:哪个啊
Lucia: Which one?
Lucia:我刚看过了
Lucia: I just checked it.
Shure: 都没有是吧
Shure: There's nothing, right?
Lucia:没有他说他神通那个取了但是
Lucia: No, he said he took it but...
Lucia:但是我觉得他我觉得他没取
Lucia: But I think he didn't take it.
Lucia:你看啊就是
Lucia: You see, it's just...
Shure: 嗯嗯嗯嗯
Shure: Mm, mm, mm, mm.
Lucia:对然后这个我觉得他也没取
Lucia: Right, and this one, I think he didn't take it either.
Lucia:他是
Lucia: He...
Lucia:他好像是说这个他取了还是怎么啊
Lucia: He seemed to say he took it or something.
Lucia:不他是说另外的那个他取了
Lucia: No, he said he took the other one.
Shure: 哦我刚刚那个还没说完
Shure: Oh, I haven't finished what I was saying earlier.
Shure: 所以你明天可以带一个
Shure: So you can bring something tomorrow.
Shure: 就是二手的物品
Shure: Like a second-hand item.
Shure: 就是交换那种拍卖
Shure: For a swap auction kind of thing.
Shure: 啊哎呦我天呐
Shure: Oh my gosh!
Shure: 我以为你你要带什么东西
Shure: I thought you were bringing something.
Shure: 是要问我去API带什么东西
Shure: Are you asking me what to bring to the API?
Shure: 我靠没看你引用的
Shure: I didn't see your reference.
Shure: 哎呦都整岔劈了
Shure: Oh, this is so confusing.
Shure: 我说你去API把我卖了
Shure: I said you could sell me at the API.
Shure: 卖了干什么
Shure: What for?
Shure: 我是我我是什么啊
Shure: What am I, anyway?
Shure: （日语）
Shure: 误会都是一个美
Shure: A misunderstanding is beautiful.
Shure: 丽的误会
Shure: A beautiful misunderstanding.
其他人:600
Others: 600
其他人:那你能看清吗
Others: Can you see clearly?
Shure: 你现在就是海盗
Shure: You look like a pirate now.
Shure: 要给你配个眼罩吗
Shure: Want me to get you an eye patch?
Katrina: 哈哈哈配个那个海盗的那个
Katrina: Haha, get a pirate one.
Shure: 对
Shure: Yes.
Shure: there once the shape broke broken c
Shure: There once the shape broke broken c
Shure: 哒哒哒哒
Shure: Da da da da
Shure: million of tea
Shure: Million of tea
Shure: 我寻思玩玩玩
Shure: I just want to have fun.
Shure: 这么变态的吧
Shure: Is it really that crazy?
Shure: 啊
Shure: Huh?
Shure: 没有没有没有没有没有
Shure: No, no, no, no, no.
其他人: 我可以回去了
Others: Can I go back now?
其他人:我可以坐在这里度假
Others: Can I sit here and relax?
其他人：不需要再坐在这里debug
Others: No need to sit here and debug anymore.
Alice:雨轩你有没有买一个地毯绿色的
Alice: Yuxuan, did you buy a green carpet?
Alice:我好像把你的拆错了
Alice: I think I opened the wrong one.
Katrina: 拆呗没关系啊
Katrina: It's fine, open it.
Alice:但是我你叫什么
Alice: But I... what's your name?
Katrina: 你帮我拆快递我不是更省事了吗
Katrina: You're helping me open my packages, that's easier for me.
Alice:就是你是小叉吗
Alice: Are you Xiao Cha?
Katrina: 小叉
Katrina: Xiao Cha.
Alice:啊就是你的
Alice: Oh, it's yours.
Alice:呃收件名
Alice: The recipient's name...
Alice:那我是
Alice: Then I am
Jake:杨鑫鑫是吧
Jake: Yang Xinxin, right?
其他人：杨鑫鑫
Others: Yang Xinxin
Shure: 杨鑫鑫
Shure: Yang Xinxin
Shure: great杨鑫鑫
Shure: Great, Yang Xinxin
Jake:哈哈哈
Jake: Hahaha
Alice:哦果然拿错了
Alice: Oh, I took the wrong one after all
Lucia:我靠我要爆粗口了
Lucia: Damn, I'm about to curse
Shure: 没事忘掉忘掉
Shure: It's okay, forget about it
Alice:我把那个地毯给你
Alice: I'll give you that rug
Alice:我说怎么感觉好像跟我印象不太一样
Alice: I was wondering why it felt different from what I remembered
Lucia:他那几个肯定没取上
Lucia: He definitely didn't get those
Lucia:然后他非
Lucia: And then he insisted
Lucia:跟我说申通这他取了
Lucia: Telling me he got it from Shentong
Lucia:问题这也没有啊
Lucia: But there's nothing here!
Lucia:然后那几个他也没取上
Lucia: And he didn't get those either
Lucia:然后他非
Lucia: And then he insisted
Lucia:说是然后他非说是驿站弄错了
Lucia: Saying it was the station's mistake
Shure: 你把我卖了
Shure: You sold me out
Shure: 你舍得吗
Shure: Would you really?
Katrina: 公费买了很多娃娃
Katrina: Bought a lot of dolls with public funds
Katrina: 哈哈哈
Katrina: Hahaha
其他人:公费娃娃
Others: Public fund dolls
Jake:公费娃娃
Jake: Public fund dolls
Shure: 什么公费娃娃
Shure: What public fund dolls?
Jake:不知道
Jake: No idea
Shure: 他在想什么
Shure: What's he thinking?
Jake:挂着然后我再改版改版
Jake: Hang on, I'll revise it again
Jake:没有没啥有
Jake: Nothing, nothing useful
Jake:用的东西
Jake: Nothing useful
其他人：就是欢迎路亚抵京
Others: Just welcome Luya to Beijing
Jake:我再改吧我再改改
Jake: I'll revise it again, I'll revise it
Shure: 玩弄我是吧
Shure: You're playing with me, right?
Jake:走我们去
Jake: Let's go
Jake:我们直接去驿站
Jake: Let's go directly to the station
其他人：哎哎我
Others: Hey, hey, I
Jake:没有小车
Jake: No car
Jake:你得走去
Jake: You have to walk
其他人:草那也可以
Others: Damn, that's fine
Jake:可以啊
Jake: Sure
其他人:等一会拿麦当劳的时候一起
Others: Let's get McDonald's together later.
其他人:麦当劳肯定不在一个地方啊
Others: McDonald's definitely isn't in the same place.
Alice:他在哪呢
Alice: Where is it?
Jake:有他们对
Jake: They have it.
Jake:他们有几个地方
Jake: They have a few locations.
Jake:但确实
Jake: But indeed.
Alice:啊你
Alice: Ah, you...
Alice:这个是你买的吧
Alice: Did you buy this?
Jake:哎对啊
Jake: Yeah, right.
Jake:问问问问
Jake: Ask, ask, ask.
Jake:这个师傅那跑腿
Jake: That delivery guy ran.
Shure: 你你试试
Shure: You, you try it.
Jake:咱找咱们还是没找
Jake: Did we find it or not?
Shure: 来你试试
Shure: Come on, you try it.
Lucia:这胶带看起来很像我的
Lucia: This tape looks like mine.
Lucia:但他名字不是我
Lucia: But the name isn't mine.
Lucia:所以我认为应该也不是
Lucia: So I think it shouldn't be.
Lucia:我不知道小什么什么
Lucia: I don't know who "Xiao something something" is.
Lucia:我写的都是朱先生啊
Lucia: I always write "Mr. Zhu."
其他人：我现在知道为什么这个机上全都是烟
Others: Now I know why there's smoke everywhere in the machine.
其他人：我估计每个人都这样
Others: I bet everyone does this.
Shure: 啊那只有我
Shure: Ah, it's only me.
Shure: 那天chua只有我
Shure: That day, it was only me and Chua.
Jake:什么隐
Jake: What's hidden?
其他人:就是我记不记得这个道路上全都是隐
Others: Do you remember there were hidden things all over the road?
Jake:哦哦哦哦
Jake: Oh, oh, oh, oh.
其他人：估计每个人都这样
Others: I bet everyone does this.
Jake:搞笑
Jake: Funny.
Shure: there once did the shape of broken sea
Shure: There once did the shape of broken sea.
Lucia:为什么你背后
Lucia: Why is it behind you?
Shure: 他背后怎么了
Shure: What's behind him?
Jake:你背后怎么了
Jake: What's behind you?
Lucia:不是这不是
Lucia: It's not, this is not...
Lucia:是他贴的还是你帮他贴的
Lucia: Did he stick it or did you help him stick it?
Lucia:我是不是
Lucia: Am I...
其他人:啊没关系啊
Others: Ah, it's okay.
Lucia:啊哈哈哈哈哈哈
Lucia: Ah ha ha ha ha ha.
Jake:谁贴的
Jake: Who stuck it?
Shure: 不知道
Shure: I don't know.
其他人:感觉只有修硕能干出来这种事情
Others: It feels like only Shure could do such a thing.
Shure: 我没有这么自恋
Shure: I'm not that narcissistic.
Shure: 我每次贴东西都是代表
Shure: Every time I stick something, it means...
Shure: 是我的东西才会贴上
Shure: It's my stuff that gets the sticker.
其他人：那我是你的
Others: Then I'm yours.
Shure: 你不是我的
Shure: You're not mine.
Shure: 你别恶心我
Shure: Don't disgust me.
其他人:181818
Others: 181818
其他人:记住丢烟头
Others: Remember to throw away the cigarette butt.
Jake:哈哈哈傻屌
Jake: Hahaha, idiot.
Lucia:哈哈哈哈哈哈哈
Lucia: Hahahahahaha.
Jake:哈哈哈哈
Jake: Hahahaha.
Shure: fireinthehole
Shure: Fire in the hole.
Lucia:你不说可能还没人录到这个细节
Lucia: If you hadn't mentioned it, no one might have recorded this detail.
其他人：不是我要做
Others: I wasn't going to do it.
其他人：你看还有这个处理
Others: Look, there's even this handling.
Lucia:哈哈哈神经
Lucia: Hahaha, you're crazy.
Shure: 他昨天在二楼的时候脱光了
Shure: He stripped naked on the second floor yesterday.
Jake:他他他对
Jake: He, he, yeah.
Jake:他傍晚时候要想洗澡
Jake: He wanted to take a shower in the evening.
Jake:然后他不知道二楼还在没关
Jake: Then he didn't know the second floor wasn't closed yet.
其他人：我洗头洗头
Others: I was washing my hair.
其他人:我就指着上半身
Others: I was pointing at the upper body.
Jake:对
Jake: Right.
Shure: 然后就被摄像头全录下来了
Shure: Then it was all recorded by the camera.
Shure: 哎没事
Shure: Hey, it's okay.
Shure: 那上半身看看怕什么
Shure: Showing the upper body, what's there to fear?
Shure: 哈哈哈给你360度还原你的骨架
Shure: Hahaha, giving you a 360-degree view of your skeleton.
Lucia:害怕了
Lucia: I'm scared now.
其他人：卧槽昨天晚上导数据
Others: Damn, transferring data last night.
Shure: 应该去往中间看一
Shure: Should have looked at the middle.
Alice:别把我的狗踢翻了
Alice: Don't kick over my dog.
Jake:我不敢动它不敢动它
Jake: I don't dare move it, don't dare move it.
Jake:它咬我
Jake: It bites me.
其他人:不敢想象在这烧狗晚上得多丑
Others: Can't imagine how ugly it would be to burn the dog here at night.
其他人:哎我靠
Others: Oh my god.
Shure: 我们烤过的
Shure: We've roasted it before.
Jake:烤了烤了3个小时
Jake: Roasted for 3 hours.
Jake:没没着火
Jake: Didn't catch fire.
其他人：我不是后悔了
Others: I don't regret it.
Jake:哈哈哈后悔了
Jake: Hahaha, regret it now.
其他人:不敢想象在这烧烤得有多少在这烧
Others: I can't imagine how many people are grilling here.
Alice:在这烧烤
Alice: Grilling here.
Alice:手都快抡冒烟了
Alice: My hands are almost smoking from waving so much.
Lucia:不是那为啥还是欢迎欢迎
Lucia: But why are we still welcoming?
Lucia:我提亲啊
Lucia: I'm proposing.
Jake:因为这是最后一个
Jake: Because this is the last one.
Jake:我再给你们这群加上
Jake: I'll add to this group.
Lucia:太奇怪了
Lucia: That's so weird.
Lucia:能把它关掉吗哈哈哈
Lucia: Can you turn it off, hahaha.
Jake:哈哈哈我再加几个
Jake: Hahaha, I'll add a few more.
Jake:好吧让大家一起尴尬
Jake: Okay, let's make everyone awkward together.
Lucia:对对对大家全都加上去
Lucia: Yeah, yeah, add everyone up there.
Jake:好好好好欢迎欢迎
Jake: Alright, alright, welcome, welcome.
Shure: 他们朝我扔泥巴行吗
Shure: Can they throw mud at me?
Lucia:欢迎各位帝京
Lucia: Welcome to the capital.
Lucia:这怎么关啊
Lucia: How do you turn this off?
Jake:欢迎修硕抵京
Jake: Welcome Shure to the capital.
Shure: 我抵通好吧
Shure: I arrived at Tong, okay?
Jake:抵通可以可以
Jake: Arrived at Tong, okay, okay.
Shure: 人人以为我抵制
Shure: Everyone thought I was resisting.
Jake:抵制
Jake: Resisting.
其他人:坏了艾斯克尔又又过不了
Others: Oh no, Esker failed again.
Jake:抵制什么呀
Jake: Resisting what?
Jake:你要抵制什么呀哈哈哈
Jake: What are you resisting, hahaha.
其他人：不要再说了
Others: Don't say it anymore.
其他人：再说SKR又过不了
Others: If you say it again, SKR won't pass.
Shure: 抵制通货膨胀呢
Shure: Resisting inflation.
其他人:再说我又要打打打款机了
Others: If you say it again, I'll hit the machine again.
Shure: 通货膨胀可以
Shure: Inflation is okay.
Jake:呵呵呵
Jake: Haha.
Shure: 抵制一下吧
Shure: Let's resist it.
Jake:加两个加两个
Jake: Add two, add two.
Jake:先加一个求数
Jake: Add one first.
Jake:就用你的这个
Jake: Just use yours.
Jake:你你你PPT里面那照片怎么样
Jake: What about the photo in your PPT?
Shure: 什么好
Shure: What about it?
Jake:你PPT
Jake: Your PPT.
其他人:打码的打码
Others: Pixelate it.
Jake:打码的
Jake: Pixelate it.
Shure: 你别打码的了
Shure: Don't pixelate it.
Shure: 证件照吧
Shure: ID photo, right?
Shure: （歌词）他们朝我扔泥巴
Shure: (lyrics) They threw mud at me
Shure: （歌词）我拿泥巴砌小楼
Shure: (lyrics) I used the mud to build a small building
Shure: 哎
Shure: Hey
Lucia:他有可能也拉下了
Lucia: He might have left it behind
Lucia:他把我好多快递都拉下了
Lucia: He left behind so many of my packages
其他人：那个女的吗
Others: That girl?
Lucia:然后他还非说他取了啊
Lucia: And he insisted that he picked it up
其他人：是送来那个女的吗
Others: The girl who delivered it?
Lucia:哪个哪个女生
Lucia: Which girl?
其他人：是那个女生吗
Others: Was it that girl?
Jake:他他不知道
Jake: He doesn't know
Jake:群里不知道是什么人
Jake: The group doesn't know who it is
其他人：哦不知道
Others: Oh, they don't know
Lucia:对群里不知道是
Lucia: Yeah, the group doesn't know
其他人:我靠这是什么
Others: Whoa, what is this
Katrina: 这是门把手的那个
Katrina: It's the door handle
其他人:我靠这么帅
Others: Wow, it's so cool
Katrina: 这么便宜
Katrina: So cheap
Katrina: 竟然是两个吗
Katrina: Is it really two of them?
其他人： 不高级
Others: Not fancy
其他人：我咋这么可爱
Others: Why am I so cute
Shure: 我看看走
Shure: Let me see, let's go
Jake:走我们去取
Jake: Let's go pick it up
其他人:走走let's go
Others: Let's go, let's go, let's go
Katrina: 给你一个吧
Katrina: I'll give you one
Katrina: 看看嗯
Katrina: Check it out
Katrina: 咱俩那个门把手
Katrina: Our door handle
其他人:let's go
Others: Let's go
Katrina: 我是我是我是
Katrina: I am, I am, I am
Jake:我问一下
Jake: Let me ask
Katrina: 这样那我是左手
Katrina: So I'm left-handed
Jake:我先问一下这个你的胶到了吗
Jake: Let me ask first, has your glue arrived?
Katrina: 他应该是一个左手一个右手
Katrina: It should be one left hand, one right hand
Shure: 都是这样都是这样
Shure: Yeah, that's how it is, that's how it is
Shure: 没事随便吧
Shure: It's fine, whatever
Katrina: 那放我家去吧
Katrina: Then put it at my place
Katrina: 这是我们最后一天
Katrina: This is our last day
Katrina: 装饰的对纯装饰
Katrina: Decorating, yeah, just decorating
Alice:我先试试能贴不能吧
Alice: I'll try to see if it sticks first
其他人：你还买个Jelly cat
Other people: You even bought a Jelly cat?
其他人：你是会上树的哦
Other people: You know how to climb trees?
其他人：你是会装饰的
Other people: You know how to decorate?
其他人：哈哈什么Jelly cat
Other people: Haha what Jelly cat?
Katrina: 我买了只小狐狸
Katrina: I bought a little fox.
Katrina: 还给他配了一条围巾
Katrina: And I got it a scarf.
Katrina: 呵呵
Katrina: Hehe.
其他人:我靠我一会要看看
Other people: Wow, I need to see that later.
其他人:如果好如果好看的话我也要买一个
Other people: If it looks good, I want to buy one too.
Jake:走走走取快递去
Jake: Let's go get the package.
Shure: 哇
Shure: Wow.
其他人:一一定一定
Other people: Definitely, definitely.
其他人:一会要让我看那个小狐狸
Other people: Let me see that little fox later.
Katrina: 我找找真的没看见哎
Katrina: I can't find it, really haven't seen it.
其他人:一定要让我看看
Other people: You must let me see it.
其他人:如果好看的话我买的快递都在这吗
Other people: If it looks good, are all my packages here?
Lucia:如果好看我买了个小鸟
Lucia: If it looks good, I bought a little bird.
Lucia:啊
Lucia: Ah.
其他人:啊不肯定不全
Other people: Ah, definitely not all of them.
其他人:应该不全
Other people: Probably not all of them.
Lucia:不全肯百分百不全
Lucia: Definitely not all of them.
其他人:你的手机上能看到哪些快递群
Other people: Can you see which packages are in the group on your phone?
Lucia:全哎
Lucia: All of them.
Lucia:这好可爱
Lucia: This is so cute.
Katrina: 哦对
Katrina: Oh right.
Jake:我试试
Jake: Let me try.
Lucia:可可爱爱
Lucia: So cute.
Jake:这摩的呵呵呵还挺可爱的这摩的
Jake: This little thing, hehe, it's really cute, this little thing.
Shure: （歌词）呜呜呜呜呜呜呜呜呜呜
Shure: (Lyrics) Ooo ooo ooo ooo ooo ooo ooo.
Shure: 呜呜呜呜呜呜呜
Shure: Ooo ooo ooo ooo ooo ooo ooo.
Shure: 呜呜呜呜
Shure: Ooo ooo ooo ooo.
Lucia:这反正老板早晚要知道的
Lucia: Anyway, the boss will find out sooner or later.
其他人：这么便宜的围巾
Other people: Such a cheap scarf.
Jake:这是围巾啊
Jake: This is the scarf?
Katrina: 没有没有这只是围巾的价格哈哈
Katrina: No, no, that's just the price of the scarf, haha.
其他人:哈哈哈狐狸的价格你就别看了
Other people: Hahaha, don't even look at the price of the fox.
其他人:反正也不是你出钱
Other people: Anyway, you're not paying for it.
Katrina: 预算拉满其他多的我自己提
Katrina: I've maxed out the budget, I'll cover the rest myself.
Shure: 不这个狐狸是是老板出钱
Shure: No, the fox is paid for by the boss.
其他人：200块钱吧
Other people: 200 yuan, right?
其他人:那个狐狸我感觉得200200加一个围巾
Others: That fox feels like 200200 plus a scarf.
Shure: 是我们的围巾
Shure: It's our scarf.
Jake:我看看围巾是啥
Jake: Let me see what the scarf is.
Shure: 室内装饰的一部分
Shure: It's part of the interior decor.
其他人:一会先买家秀一下
Others: Let's have a buyer show it off first.
其他人:如果好我也买一个
Others: If it's good, I'll buy one too.
其他人:卧槽这个这个
Others: Whoa, this, this...
其他人:明天就是一个进货的阶段
Others: Tomorrow is just a restocking phase.
Jake:对对明天
Jake: Yes, yes, tomorrow.
Jake:对是的
Jake: Yes, it is.
Katrina: 对没到呢
Katrina: Yes, it's not here yet.
Katrina: 他在那个菜鸟驿站
Katrina: It's at the Cainiao station.
Jake:明天每人带个眼镜
Jake: Tomorrow, everyone bring glasses.
Jake:然后你们就对
Jake: And then you'll...
Katrina: 给他建模
Katrina: Build a model for him.
Jake:好
Jake: Okay.
Katrina: 走吧要去拿吗
Katrina: Let's go, should we pick it up?
Jake:去拿去拿
Jake: Let's go pick it up.
Jake:走走咱俩咋去
Jake: Let's go, how do we go?
Katrina: 今天开的没取这不行
Katrina: It's not open today, that's not okay.
其他人:咱俩咋去
Others: How do we go?
Jake:走去
Jake: Let's walk.
其他人:走过去很远
Others: It's very far to walk.
Jake:那怎么办
Jake: Then what should we do?
Jake:有共享单车吗
Jake: Are there shared bikes?
Shure: 没有只能走过去
Shure: No, we can only walk.
Jake:开车开开车方便吗
Jake: Is it convenient to drive?
Jake:开车方便去吗
Jake: Is it convenient to drive there?
Jake:跟刘帅说一下
Jake: Tell Choiszt.
Jake:开刘帅车过去
Jake: Drive Choiszt's car there.
Shure: 有帅的车不
Shure: Is Choiszt's car here?
Shure: 我不敢开
Shure: I don't dare to drive.
其他人:沉迷甜点无法自拔
Others: Obsessed with desserts and can't get away.
Katrina: 有点刮蹭了
Katrina: It's a bit scratched.
Katrina: 有点赔不起
Katrina: It's a bit too expensive to pay for.
其他人:对啊
Others: Yeah.
Shure: 对啊
Shure: Yeah.
Shure: 虽然是个老的
Shure: Even though it's old...
Shure: 但是也是奔驰E呢
Shure: But it's still a Mercedes E-class.
Katrina: 天呐我们这几天有100多个快递吧
Katrina: Oh my god, we have over 100 packages these days.
Katrina: 啊感觉有每个人十几个
Katrina: Ah, feels like everyone has over a dozen.
Shure: 啊有了
Shure: Oh, there are.
Shure: 真有了差不多
Shure: Really, there almost are.
Katrina: 我有十几个我
Katrina: I have over a dozen myself.
Jake:我有20多个
Jake: I have more than 20.
Katrina: 你也有20多个
Katrina: You have more than 20 too?
Jake:没有我我这些东西很多的
Jake: No, I have a lot of these things.
Tasha: 取麦当劳吗
Tasha: Picking up McDonald's?
Shure: 你看我给你最省
Shure: Look, I saved you the most.
Shure: 我就两个
Shure: I only have two.
Jake:麦当劳谢谢您
Jake: McDonald's, thank you.
Tasha: 麦当劳不是送到门口吗
Shure: 给你省了多少经费
Shure: How much budget did I save you?
Tasha: 我选择这里
Tasha: I choose here.
其他人:那我们直接走推荐
Others: Then let's just go with the recommendation.
Tasha: 走去哪里
Tasha: Where are we going?
Jake:驿站这谁
Jake: Who's at the station?
其他人:麦当劳就一公里还开车去麦
Others: McDonald's is just a kilometer away, still driving there?
Tasha: 麦当劳送到门口了
Tasha: McDonald's delivers to the door.
Jake:没有没有
Jake: No, no.
Jake:咱是取快递
Jake: We're picking up a package.
Jake:咱是要取快递
Jake:走吧
Jake: Let's go.
Shure: 再见
Shure: Goodbye.
Jake:确实这
Jake: Indeed this...
其他人:这谁贴的
Others: Who posted this?
其他人:不知道刘帅贴的吧
Others: Don't know, maybe Choiszt.
Shure: 不知道啊
Shure: No idea.
其他人：刘帅贴的吧
Others: Probably Choiszt.
其他人:啥呀
Others: What?
其他人:不是我不一直在这呆着
Others: It's not me, I've been here all along.
其他人：就是你
Others: It's definitely you.
Katrina: 不是你吗
Katrina: Wasn't it you?
Shure: 不是我真不是我
Shure: It wasn't me, it really wasn't me.
Katrina: 调监控
Katrina: Check the surveillance.
其他人：我操这个一定要查出来
Others: Damn, we need to find out who did this.
Tasha: 鸡蛋羹不得搁
Tasha: You can't put the eggs in the custard.
Katrina: 哈哈哈哈哈哈
Katrina: Hahaha.
Tasha: 搁鸡蛋进去
Tasha: Put the eggs in.
Jake:挖掘三尺
Jake: Dig three feet deep.
Jake:你想想你想想
Jake: Think about it, just think about it.
Lucia:早知道早知道
Lucia: If I had known earlier...
Lucia:我就不告诉你了
Lucia: I wouldn't have told you.
Jake:你贴的时候有没有戴眼镜
Jake: Did you wear glasses when you posted it?
Lucia:原来你不知道
Lucia: So you didn't know.
Jake:不知道
Jake: I didn't know.
Lucia:哈哈不知道
Lucia: Haha, you didn't know.
Shure: 不知道不清楚
Shure: Didn't know, not clear.
Jake:你你想想贴的时候戴没戴眼镜
Jake: Think, did you wear glasses when you posted it?
Shure: 我不知道谁贴的呀
Shure: I don't know who posted it.
Jake:哈哈哈哈
Jake: Hahaha.
其他人：问你贴时候带没带
Others: He's asking if you wore glasses when posting it.
Shure: 什么贴啥
Shure: Posted what?
Shure: 哈哈哈
Shure: Hahaha.
Jake:走走走哈哈哈
Jake: Let's go, let's go, hahaha.
Lucia:这个安康鱼也是你的吗
Lucia: Is this monkfish also yours?
Shure: 这是我我们老的队名
Shure: This was our old team name.
Jake:那根线是谁的呀
Jake: Whose line is that?
Lucia:which one
Lucia: Which one?
Shure: 上面写名了应该
Shure: It should have a name on it.
Lucia:啵啵啵啵
Lucia: Bo bo bo bo.
Shure: 刘宇轩
Shure: Liu Yuxuan.
Katrina: 到
Katrina: Here.
Katrina: 哈哈哈嗯嗯嗯
Katrina: Hahaha, yeah yeah yeah.
Shure: 你现在怎么自己不接个好的呢
Shure: Why don't you get a good one yourself now?
Jake:S1C04吗
Jake: S1C04, right?
Jake:是吗你是C04吗
Jake: Is it? Are you C04?
Katrina: 我不记得我是谁谁谁
Katrina: I don't remember who I am.
Jake:是那就C04吧
Jake: If so, then you're C04.
Jake:呵呵呵呵
Jake: Hehehe.
Katrina: 我去拿个充电宝
Katrina: I'll go get a power bank.
Shure: 我好像是C01
Shure: I think I'm C01.
Jake:你是C01 C02啊
Jake: You're C01 or C02.
Shure: 对
Shure: Right.
Lucia:啊哈那我可能是C04
Lucia: Ah, then I might be C04.
Jake:C03
Jake: C03.
Jake:他先扫的你后扫的你就是C04
Jake: He scanned first, you scanned after, so you're C04.
Shure: 我是C01
Shure: I'm C01.
Lucia:所以呢这个号有什么用吗
Lucia: So, what use is this number?
Jake:就是模型的代号啊
Jake: It's the model's code.
Shure: 这是我们的数字生命的代号模型
Shure: This is our digital life code model.
Jake:是的模型3D
Jake: Yes, the 3D model.
Shure: 我们每个人都扫了一个3D的模
Shure: Each of us scanned a 3D model.
Jake:就是你的那个
Jake: Like yours.
Jake:你你你当年的那个东西
Jake: You know, the one from back then.
Jake:走发
Jake: Go ahead.
Jake:个人
Jake: Personal.
其他人：对扫了
Others: Yes, we scanned it.
其他人：我当年的人那个
Others: My one from back then.
Jake:对
Jake: Yeah.
其他人:我觉得那个还是很很好用的
Others: I think it’s still pretty useful.
Jake:是的
Jake: Yes.
其他人:虽然文件比较大
Others: Though the file is quite big.
Jake:是的是的
Jake: Yes, yes.
Shure: 高保真度的Max
Shure: High-fidelity Max.
Shure: （歌词）挺拔新征程
Shure: (lyrics) A new journey begins.
Shure: （歌词）号角吹向将军
Shure: (lyrics) The bugle calls the general.
Shure: （歌词） 目标召唤在前方
Shure: (lyrics) The goal beckons ahead.
Jake:没有小车哎
Jake: No small car, huh?
Jake:问问可能
Jake: Let’s ask.
Jake:不是我们这个院子的
Jake: It’s not from our yard.
Jake:不是我们这院子的
Lucia:咱这人有点多哈哈
Lucia: There are quite a lot of people here, haha.
Jake:不是我们这院子的
Jake: It’s not from our yard.
Jake:试试试试问问
Jake: Let’s try asking.
Jake:别走留步步
Jake: Don’t go, wait.
Jake:您您是佑佑的院子吗
Jake: Are you from Youyou’s yard?
其他人：您有什么事吗
Others: Do you need something?
Jake:我们想取快递啊
Jake: We want to pick up a package.
其他人：咱们这个车
Others: Our car...
其他人：现在我要去那个送东西啊
Others: I’m going to deliver something now.
Jake:啊
Jake: Ah.
其他人：用不了
Others: Can’t use it.
Jake:送不了好
Jake: Can’t deliver? Okay.
其他人：嗯咱们那个按着那个导航
Others: Yeah, just follow the navigation.
其他人：然后那个咱自己取下
Others: And pick it up yourself.
其他人：那个车也在拉东西好嗯好吧
Others: The car is also delivering something, alright?
Jake:好我们能走
Jake: Okay, we can go.
Jake:嗯我们走吧
Jake: Yeah, let’s go.
Shure: 好吧
Shure: Alright.
Shure: 我们可以GCA了
Shure: We can GCA now.
Jake:哈哈哈摁f
Jake: Hahaha, press F.
Jake:F键
Jake: Press the F key.
Shure: f键进入载具
Shure: Press F to enter the vehicle.
Jake:哈哈哈哈哈哈哈
Jake: Hahahahahaha.
Lucia:再见再见
Lucia: Bye bye.
Lucia:哈哈哈
Lucia: Hahaha.
其他人：那一会那一会你头上就是一颗星
Others: In a while, you'll have a star above your head.
Jake:哈哈
Jake: Haha.
Shure: 不会的吧
Shure: No way.
其他人:偷车在在洛洛洛圣都是不会机智
Others: Stealing a car in Los Santos isn't that smart.
其他人:但在别的地方就不一定
Others: But in other places, it's uncertain.
Shure: 哈哈哈
Shure: Hahaha.
Lucia:什么GTA
Lucia: What, GTA?
其他人:感觉路上路
Others: Feels like on the road.
Lucia:路上哈哈哈
Lucia: On the road, hahaha.
其他人:我们如果只偷个车的话
Others: If we just steal a car.
其他人:出一嗨再往从天上掉个坦克
Others: And then drop a tank from the sky.
其他人:哈哈哈我记得有那个
Others: Hahaha, I remember there's that.
Shure: 哈哈哈
Shure: Hahaha.
其他人:有一个什么暗语
Others: There's some kind of code.
其他人:就是什么输一输一个英文单词
Others: Like entering an English word.
其他人:然后跟什么无伤跑的巨帅
Others: Then running invincibly, super cool.
其他人:子弹无限
Others: Infinite bullets.
Jake:对哎
Jake: Yeah, right.
Shure: 秘籍可多了
Shure: There are so many cheats.
Jake:咱有导航吗
Jake: Do we have a GPS?
Shure: 咱没导航咱在这瞎瞎鸡走什么呢
Shure: No GPS, we're just wandering around blindly.
Katrina: 笑自己消音是吧
Katrina: Laughing at yourself being muted?
Jake:这真打GT啊
Jake: We're really playing GT, huh?
Jake:难走哈哈哈
Jake: It's tough, hahaha.
Lucia:咱那群我怎么找不着啊
Lucia: How come I can't find our group?
Shure: 哈哈哈哈哈哈哈
Shure: Hahahahaha.
Shure: 噔噔噔噔噔噔噔
Shure: Dun dun dun dun dun dun.
Shure: 别瞎看啊
Shure: Don't look randomly.
Shure: 你没戴眼镜没事
Shure: It's okay if you're not wearing glasses.
Lucia:先去菜鸟吗
Lucia: Should we go to the noob first?
其他人:我看飞机应该没什么吧
Others: I think the plane should be fine.
Jake:你看飞机没什么
Jake: You think the plane's fine?
Lucia:菜鸟的话
Lucia: If it's the noob.
Shure: 对我们看不行
Shure: Yeah, we can't see it.
其他人:为什么谁知道的
Others: Why, who knows?
Jake:是啥呀对
Jake: What is it, right?
Shure: 没准哪个就是武装的
Shure: Maybe one of them is armed.
Shure: 谁知道这眼镜戴不戴透视啊
Shure: Who knows if these glasses have X-ray vision.
Jake:透视哈
Jake: X-ray vision, huh?
Shure: 麦塔告诉我们是没戴
Shure: Meta told us they don’t.
Lucia:如果说是那个菜鸟的话
Lucia: If it's that newbie...
Jake:哈哈哈
Jake: Hahaha
Shure: 那如果说是那个谁知道
Shure: Who knows about that?
Shure: 杨老板知道多些呢
Shure: Jake knows more about it.
Jake:那咱可不知道
Jake: I really don't know.
Jake:啥也不知道
Jake: I don't know anything.
Shure: 真不知道
Shure: Really don't know.
其他人:好非常的形象
Others: Very vivid.
其他人:对非常形象
Others: Yeah, very vivid.
Lucia: 对
Lucia: Yeah.
Lucia: 特别详细
Lucia: Very detailed.
Katrina: 这这哦这就是菜鸟一只
Katrina: This, this, oh, it's just a newbie.
Lucia:对它里面好像只发个菜鸟
Lucia: Yeah, it seems like there's only one newbie inside.
Lucia:和一个别的什么
Lucia: And something else.
Katrina: 今天得把这个取回来
Katrina: We need to get this back today.
Jake:哈哈哈哈
Jake: Hahahahaha
Shure: 哈哈哈哈
Shure: Hahahahaha
其他人:味太对了
Others: The vibe is spot on.
Jake:走走走要撞墙
Jake: Let's go, let's go, we're going to hit a wall.
Jake:哈哈哈哈
Jake: Hahahaha
其他人:要有要一个人过来给你
Others: Someone needs to come over and...
Jake:哈哈哈嚯
Jake: Hahaha, oh.